but i didn't i wanted to satisfy my own
need you know what i mean as a man it's
like a masculine i understand what
you're saying i understand
but so like for me when i work from home
i tend to not eat um because i'll just
be so you know
focused on my work i'll just i wouldn't
be able to go downstairs and make food
or or i would be able to but i just
forget sometimes my girl coming up and
bringing me food would be like i could
have done that myself but i'll
appreciate that of course that's that's
like another level of like what if the
food's trash
just because your chicken is drying my
corn
yeah like it up if you want to see
pearl's chicken
you might not want to see it
where's my chicken dry no yeah just wait
i'm not lying and she seasons in it come
on she sees it she pain you was like
there it is
oh my god the audacity of
corals wings
look at my my wings are fire
you've never anyway
okay i'll bring the hot sauce oh yeah no
i got hot sauce
yeah okay
okay um next question so
if a woman and a man are attacked in
public who is more likely to be rescued
the woman we already know the answer
hands down
men i don't
the way your questions are framed even
the last one i'm like but are men
actually fully desiring for women to
protect them or for someone to come and
rescue them like it's not it you get
what you demand let me ask the second
part of the question
why are women afraid to be out in public
when they are more likely to be rescued
i think they can't help it they're still
afraid it's just like a feeling they
have really cause i just think they're
delusional
are women afraid to be out in public
there's a lot of double standards jessie
when i was interviewing people were
women afraid to be out in public they
said they were yeah but where were they
in their house so that's why she said
the delusion
let's put it in perspective right you're
talking to women in the united kingdom
the united kingdom has a queen not a
king
but a queen this is a matriarchy by
definition
any woman in the united kingdom that
complains about the patriarchy is
obviously delusional
however
this mentality is all over the world so
even in the united states women complain
about a patriarchy
we live in a world where women have an
advantage over men in basically every
aspect
women will
generally
have more benefits
we talk about the pay gap
like women make less than men but they
actually get way more benefits than men
get because men don't have
repro uh
you know
birth control we don't have anything
like that offered to us we don't have
paternity leave we don't have
uh the right to be able to brought back
to our jobs after our woman has a baby
we don't have any of those sorts of
things
so
there's a lot of delusion going on so
when we're when when women go out
thinking that they're always in danger
yeah that you you want people to be
aware of the dangers but i think yeah
there's a lot of people out there
many of the women have this idea that
yeah
i can
play the victim
and still be aggressive
and i think that's i want to talk about
the pay gap actually
we should come back to that the pay gap
do you mean that myth um yeah
do you guys believe there's some some
back and forth to it but i'm curious i
don't know though because i mean look
men take more dangerous jobs obviously
we're going to get paid more for that
that's one myth depend and your realm of
work women get paid more don't they
only found some carpentry because i
don't think there's any only fans yeah
look exactly how are you gonna
pawn in general you're just not just
excuse me in general not just only fans
mm-hmm
yeah where's the pig gap there where is
the justice there but it's interesting
in general you won't hear any woman
complaining about that because it suits
exactly yeah yeah
i've met women who are electricians um
in my entire life i've worked on cruise
ships since
1999
and in my entire career i've met one
female electrician
i've met
three female engineers
and
all of them were gorgeous don't get me
wrong one of them was a lesbian
but all of them are gorgeous
and
one of the lesbian i wasn't even really
sure
but the point being is that they're out
there they will get the job and they'll
tell you about how difficult it is to be
a woman in a man's world
fine
but i don't see
lines of women
studying to be journeymen i don't see
it couldn't be me it couldn't be me no
no they don't want to complain that
they're getting paid less well yeah
we're doing a different job we try
something more dangerous yeah but even
take it in
in a in a job where let's just say it's
an office job and you got a man and
woman sitting next to each other in a
cubicle
that woman may have a smaller salary
but that doesn't mean she's getting paid
less
because when she goes on maternity leave
she's still getting paid for not doing
the work that man is still there working
every day but but even even let's say
let's say that this actually happened
right let's say that wait you got real
logically it would make no sense because
why would i hire a man if i can hire a
woman pay her less
and she does just as good just as good
or even or even better job it it doesn't
make sense for me as a business
but people don't think about that when
they're talking about these things it's
like
logically it makes no sense for a
business whose whole purpose is to make
a profit to do that when it you know one
of the largest expenses a business has
is wages
that's cherry picking to take one small
little detail or red herring they call
it take a small little detail and
inflate that and make that oh this is
this is the main point when it actually
doesn't really tell the whole story what
gets me is that they're complaining
about it so like if they were getting
paid less
then why wouldn't companies hire them
and do the same
do the same job
they either you're not doing the same
job or
who knows
so i had an incident where um sorry go
ahead go god i didn't when i used to
work at a bank in new york and um you
know this co-worker she didn't like
direct deposit so i had to physically
cash a check
and you know i split you know you split
the thing and i could see her hourly
rate i was a supervisor and
she made more money than me
you know so like when when
and she was a part-timer
and to put this into context in i think
i was there like seven years
she
had like two kids the first kid she had
she went on maternity within the first
year so she was out
even though she was working
or an employee and she came back and she
got pregnant so
when i first started to read about the
whole pay gap thing
my mind always goes back to that because
i'm thinking okay she was a part-timer
and she was making like almost you know
two to almost three bucks an hour more
than hours
so how is it how where is this payback
and not to you know one of the things i
told myself is like okay
don't make this a rule this could be an
exception it's
it's possible i have no way of knowing
but
you know when whenever this debate comes
up that's what i always think about
because i'm like somewhere there's
someone who's getting shorted one in the
in the other direction no matter what we
think about um
the pay gap issue that men are getting
paid more
for you know for whatever reason you
know i just i think there's there's a
lot up there
you know that isn't talked about enough
or we haven't seen yeah it's like you
said as well like there's plenty of jobs
that
i it's harder for men to get higher like
only fans and corn and modeling as well
because i model it's so much harder for
me to get
modelling gigs and women just you know
so easy of them so double standards
so next question okay
what is a better form of this is going
to be interesting because we're in the
uk
what is a better form of protection
owning a gun or calling the police
[Music]
depending on what area you're in okay
so if someone's trying to stab me what's
quicker
oh i'm i was thinking the context was
like you're home but
i got you
i'm pretty fast i can't run
away you are pretty fast
wait wait wait are you fast now if it's
oh yeah no no
i mean
you never know progress yeah
just just had me searching but you just
know you're falling
not right now give me a few months okay
so you said gun you said depends okay
yes
if it's just me i'd rather um police but
if i have my family i'd rather have a
gun okay which which one's the way to
answer the question one or the other
i'm going i'll say okay
yeah pick
one
is it mean the situation it doesn't
what's a better form of protection for
anyone a gun or calling the police
uh
i'm gonna say cooler than the police
okay so let me just i don't want guns in
this country just let me let me just get
this straight let me just take this
straight i'm about to get stabbed okay
i'm about to get stabbed i call the
police where i shoot him what's quicker
yeah but i don't want to kill someone
that's like
i think we've got lesser two evils i
think i'm going to be scarred by that i
just i don't want to take my i'll just
die
okay go ahead what do you think and and
to build off of your point you probably
will be scarred if you don't know how to
use that gun uh-huh
then you're going to probably kill
yourself
that's not the question
so i mean you know how to use it
assuming that you know how to use it yes
i'd absolutely go for the guy if i
didn't know how to use it i want it